well it's now just off to 10 GMT that's
just Parts midday in Khartoum and we
begin in Sudan where after just a day of
relative calm fighting has once again
resumed across the capital and its
neighboring cities the conflict between
the Army and the paramilitary force has
also reignited ethnic tensions in the
Darfur region more than 1 000 people
have now reportedly been killed in west
Darfur since the beginning of this
conflict the West Staff or doctors
Syndicate has appealed to the
International Community to stop the
violence the killings have reportedly
been carried out by gunmen mainly in the
city of elginina therefore is often the
scene of violence sparked by territorial
disputes and access to water between
tribes of African origin and Arab tribes
well let's go straight to Heber Morgan
she's across all of this from onderman
that's across the Nile River in um just
from
khartoumber the ceasefire ended just a
few hours ago and we're already seeing
fighting not only in the capital but
also in West Darfur where it's been
incredibly brutal
yes indeed now uh Saturday has been very
quiet in the capital Khartoum but since
the early hours of Sunday morning there
has been Heavy Artillery there's been
there are airstrikes in various parts of
the capital and there's been gunfire
exchange between the rapid support
forces and the Sudanese Army now this
this fire did not include the western
region of Darfur despite mediators
saying it was supposed to be Countrywide
West Darfur region especially Janina has
been the scene of intense fighting Not
Just Between the rapid support forces
and the Sudanese Army but Arab militias
Allied to the rapid support forces as
well let's not forget that Darfur has
been where there was a intercommuninal
violence and there's been ethnic
violence and a civil war for a period of
20 years so people there were already
trying to recover from uh from that
trauma and from the consequences of that
were but now with the fighting between
the rapid support forces and the
Sudanese Army the very few who can make
it outside the West R4 into neighboring
chat say that the situation there is is
catastrophic they describe Villages
being burned bodies on the ground and
that Arab militias are targeting People
based on their ethnicities with the
doctors Union in West Darfur describing
the situation as a genocide and
catastrophic due to the ongoing fighting
between the Arab Allied militias and the
rapid support forces and the residents
of westar4 but as you say civilians have
been trying to get across that border
it's been hard to get any concrete
information out of alginina given the
intensity of the fighting over the last
few weeks you talked a little bit about
the situation on the ground there is
there any help at all
it's been very hard to get assistance to
the western region of Darfur generally
speaking and Janina in West Darfur has
been even harder now the governor of
Darfur region declared the entire Darfur
region a disaster Zone because of the
humanitarian consequences of fighting
between the rapid support forces its
Arab Allied militias and the Sudanese
Army there with civilians caught in the
middle but those who are able to cross
the border describe horrific
humanitarian situations hospitals are
out of function with at least 2 000
renal dialysis patients losing their
lives over the past few weeks because of
lack of Access to Health Facilities
there are thousands of people who have
been injured as a result of the fighting
but those who leave say that their
relatives especially the injured
relatives cannot get humanitarian
Assistance or medical assistance due to
the ongoing fighting so the situation is
quite catastrophic doctors saying that
there is a there is a huge need for
humanitarian assistance but due to the
violence that is being very hard to
deliver to those in westar4 at the
moment hibber Morgan they're on the
ground for us in onderman in Sudan thank
you very much Heba well as hibber just
mentioned thousands of people are trying
to flee that violence in West Darfur and
they're escaping into neighboring Chad
Zain Bas Ravi has Moana from Audrey
across the border in eastern Chad
getting out of old Janina now is
effectively taking your life into your
own hands those people that are able to
escape the besieged city and arrive here
at camps like this in Audrey they come
here and they wait for help we've been
talking to many of them and they tell
terrifying stories of exactly how
arduous it was to get out one man told
us that along the way they encountered
militias at checkpoints who beat them
who threatened their lives and who shot
at them as they were running away and
they were split up the the group that
was coming was split up and one man said
he's still trying to find his brother
they beat us and kicked us and they also
whipped us and they took all my property
my telephone and my bag and I let them
when we're coming I lost one of my
brothers on the road
when he saw that they were kicking me he
ran away and they were shooting at him
and he ran into the forest I've been
looking for him all morning I haven't
found him I don't know if they've killed
him or taken him
the kind of stories we've been hearing
from people who've been escaping the
violence it is a harrowing experience
for any adult let alone for the dozens
of children that we've seen who are now
living in these camps living out in the
open exposed to the elements we've seen
children showing signs of serious
malnutrition there there is a serious
problem of access to food and water and
hygienic conditions in these sorts of
impromptu camps and one of the most
serious problems we've seen is children
showing signs of trauma having seen
incidents of violence as they were
crossing the border into Audrey but now
that they're here they risk suffering
preventable illnesses without the proper
medical care if this is how they
continue to live for much longer
Eastern Chad
let's bring in Matt Nasheed he joins us
now he's a political analyst who covers
Sudan and he joins us from Cairo and
that we know the fighting is
intensifying and therefore it obviously
has different characteristics to what
we've been seeing in Khartoum they're a
host of groups involved can you explain
for our viewers what's driving it who's
fighting who
foreign
sure yeah I think this is what we're
seeing right now in westar4 is a number
of Arab militias that are Loosely
connected and allies historically of the
rapid support forces others heavily
recruitment from their base
um they you know their tribe comprises
um the senior leadership of the rsf uh
in a lot of cases and so what we're
seeing right now is the consequences of
Decades of rewarding impunity now taking
shape once again in West R4 and what I
mean by that is that attacks like this
while this is now I wouldn't say um this
is unprecedented since 2003 there have
been brutal attacks that have been
taking place in Westar for since uh
former authoritarian leader Omar Bashir
fell in 2019 and there's hopes of
democracy in Sudan but every single time
there was brutal assaults on the
non-arab communities there whether it
was over disputed land or Water
Resources there was no action taken to
hold perpetrators accountable and
instead they continued to be emboldened
often recruited often armed and given
both
um you know legal immunity and cover by
the rsf that feared of that feared
effectively of
antagonizing old tribal allies so now
where this is this is the consequence of
it we're seeing communities that are
heavily armed our community is
significantly heavily armed that have no
fear whatsoever of repercussions and
that have very close ties and help and
aid from one of the main belligerents in
this war which is the rapid support
forces let me ask you a little more
about that Matt because many of these
Arab militias are aligned with the rsf
and the rsf was essentially born out of
the janjaweed which has a very brutal
history as you alluded to there in the
region are they receiving alms right now
from the rsf
it's tough it's difficult to verify but
historically they have a number of
um a number of people within these uh
you know Arab militia gangs motorcycle
bike gangs driving convoys they a number
of them are also fighters within the rsf
not all but many of them
um and so what we see is that the lines
are quite porous while the rsf and
cartoon for instance looks like you know
even this could be debatable but looks
to be more in comparison to Darfur as a
more concrete entity in Darfur the lines
are so porous between
um Arab militias that operate under no
chain of command from the rsf whatsoever
nor pretend to be nor put up the facade
of doing so but at the same time having
a number of the members
um Within These these communities that
are also employed and fight along the
rsf and with the rsf as well and so this
is this is what we see the integration
between the dark history of how the rsf
came into being and
um and and how that history is replaying
itself out right now with the original
gender weed militias in Darfur
um the the the contradiction I would add
is that in past the junction weed was
armed and weaponized by the military now
that we're seeing is that actually these
militias are being armed and weaponized
and and given um immunity by the rsf
itself which formed out of them so
there's a bit of an irony there uh not
the talks to try to end the conflict in
Sudan and Jeddah have been very much
centered on cartoon now given the number
of armed groups involved in the Darfur
fighting who do you think should be
trying to tackle this
well well I I think right now what we're
seeing is is this is partially due to a
complete uh Power vacuum
um that has taken place
um and as a result of that what we're
seeing is that malicious Loosely connect
with the rsf taking advantage of that to
settle scores and consolidate their
control over disputed resources and
that's translating into uh violence with
an ethnic ethnic face to it where
they're targeting People based on
ethnicity and so as a result of that I
think some of the solutions need to be
Revisited from
um you know from from 2006 2007 and
onwards we need to start contemplating
about a peacekeeping mission for
instance and I know that would be
incredibly difficult from a technical
and legal perspective but we we need to
start raising this uh right now within
the highest corridors of power right now
because at the moment there's absolutely
no monitoring and there's no actor right
now present in Sudan that has the
capability nor political will or
intention to try to provide any some
less of security to communities right
now in Darfur so what that means
effectively is that those are their most
militarized and have the most backing
from factions in cartoon such as the rsf
and their tribal allies can essentially
go on a killing spree with absolutely no
repercussion so there needs to be
independent monitoring and that itself
can provide assemblance of protection
because it raises the Specter of
accountability once that once
perpetrators are identified
Matt Nasheed the political analyst who
covers Sudan speaking to us from Cairo
thank you for joining us again Matt
really great to get your thoughts here
again on Al Jazeera